A lot of people were having questions about YAML files.
People had problems getting the YAML files configured correctly.
Could you go on to what exactly that is and what you need in it?
Sure. To the extent that I can. I, like you, am also a little bit new to Goggle App Engine.
A YAML file is just this configuration file that App Engine uses.
It defines what the main file of your app is going to be.
Like what file is going to load first Python. What libraries need to be loaded.
App Engine runs in this kind of sandbox situation. That might not be the right word.
But basically libraries that you have installed on your system aren't necessarily accessible,
and libraries that ship with App Engine aren't necessarily accessible in App Engine
unless you tell the YAML file, "Hey I want to use this library."
This helps Google, presumably, deploy your code properly when they deploy it on their machines.
So it's not a difficult piece of technology.
Basically, if you don't know, I would ask in the forums.
I've been doing a lot of googling myself to get my YAML file in order.
That's sort of the nature of the business.
Try to stay out of these configuration files as much as you can.
When we make my cut available, I'll include the YAML file that I've been using
which is very simple.
I just based it on the "hello, world!" examples from the App Engine website. Okay.